controversial tweets a canceled spin-off
and an uncertain future in the Star Wars
Universe it's finally clear how the
Mandalorian is dealing with Cara Dune
Star Wars fans were eagerly awaiting the
third season of the Mandalorian for what
felt like the longest time as viewers
geared up for the latest Avengers of
grogu and din jarin one particular plot
thread continued to dangle in the air
and solved in the wake of a major
controversy Cara Dune played by former
MMA star and American Gladiator Gina
Carano was last seen in the second
season of The Mandalorian at the time
carer was seen helping rescue grogu from
moth Gideon played by Breaking Bad Alum
Giancarlo Esposito she was later to
continue her work as a martial for New
Republic forces which would have lent
itself easily to a dune centered
spin-off Rangers of the new Republic
however will apparently never see the
light of day everything changed when
Gina Carano was fired by lucasfilm in
February 2021 the firing happened in the
wake of a series of Twitter and
Instagram compost in which she made
controversial statements regarding the
covid-19 pandemic masking pronoun usage
and the Holocaust among other topics I
didn't even know what people were
talking about I was just not clued in
carano's post left dune's fate
unresolved and fan speculation has run
rampant ever since viewers have wondered
if the character might be killed off or
recast others thought she may continue
to exist in The Ether of the larger Star
Wars World alive but never spoken of
again after months of speculation fans
finally have an answer to their
simmering questions the Mandalorian
executive producers Dave filoni and Rick
famo yiwa have spoken out about Dune
status within the Mandalorian world and
the Star Wars Universe speaking ahead of
the release of the Mandalorian season 3
far more you were admitted that he and
Siri's Creator John Favreau approached
the subject of Cara Dunes existence
carefully telling deadline Cara was a
big pass and continues as a carrot said
to be part of the world it's had to be
addressed in the creative and John
Favreau took the time to think think
about that however they weren't overly
concerned about the topic of Doom
because the show's two Central
characters DIN jarin and grogu are still
in place as FAMU yiwa told the
publication ultimately it felt like a
servicing of that and around the
mandalorians when asked about Dunes
exact whereabouts in the larger Star
Wars World Dave filoni told deadline
it's a big Galaxy and we have many
characters in it many characters are
fighting for their screen time we'll
just have to see as the season unfolds
what the adventures are polony added
that Doom was a good character and while
she was vital to jaron's formative years
the series is currently concerned with
his growth beyond that period of time so
it appears that there are no plans to
revive Dune as a character but that she
will continue to exist in the general
Cosmic soup that is the extended Star
Wars Universe I need a marshall what
about Marshall Doom
after she brought in moff Gideon she was
recruited by Special Forces valoni also
noted that something even more important
is a foot in the Mandalorian season 3.
as it would be about the Mandalorian
World At Large the executive produced
its whole deadline now season three is
mainly dealing with mandalorians and the
Mandalorian Saga the Mandalorian tale it
also appears that din jarin's world will
generally be brought in to include a
larger number of people including people
he's met between adventures with felony
teasing there are different characters
he's met since Boca Town who take a lot
more prominence which makes sense where
his Arc is going the story of him and
grogu specifically when asked if they've
gotten requests to bring Kara Doom back
to the Mandalorian polony told deadline
I get requests across the board for all
types of characters I've been with Star
Wars as coming on 20 years it's a great
Galaxy the hardest thing is finding time
and space for everyone out there he
added that there are so many characters
battling for screen time within the
universe but that the purpose of the
Mandalorian is tell the story of jarin
and grogu basically it would seem that
there are no current plans to use Dune
in season three however it will be
interesting to see if anything
transpires in a galaxy far far away in
the near future
[Music]
foreign